en la siguiente figura todos los ángulos
son rectos ok se refiere a que esté
recto esté recto
este de acá también creo que es la idea
nos preguntan cuál es el área en
unidades cuadradas de la figura bueno
pues se ve como que esta figura se puede
dividir en varios rectángulos justo
porque tienen muchos ángulos rectos
entonces por ejemplo podríamos encontrar
este rectángulo de acá y esta parte es
un rectángulo con la 2 6 y 8 6 y 8 de
modo que su área es 6 x 8 o sea 48 48 de
manera similar aquí abajo tenemos otro
rectángulo de 6 por 8 déjame lo marco
nos quedaría algo como así
sería este rectángulo de acá y una vez
más su área es de 6 x 8 o sea 48 y
después de esto qué más podemos hacer
pues me quedan estos dos pequeños
rectángulos que voy a pintar con otro
color que ahora cada uno de ellos tiene
la 2 3 y 4 entonces el área de aquí es
12 y el área de acá también es 12
también es 12 por lo tanto el área total
de la figura es sumar cada una de estas
áreas 48 con 12 son 62 y 48 50 y 10 60
ajá y luego hay que sumar otros 60
porque otra vez 12 y 48 son 60 60 y 60
son 120 y entonces el área de la figura
es 120 unidades cuadradas la respuesta
sería c
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 36 en
el problema 36 dice que un campo de
s'agaró el color verde un campo
rectangular mide 360 y 3 pies de largo y
240 pies de ancho y nos preguntan
cuántos acres tiene el campo y nos dicen
aquí que un acres son 43 mil 560 pies
cuadrados déjame dibujar el campo
y ahí tenemos el largo ahí tenemos el
ancho dice que el campo es rectangular
esto es 360 ahí
33 y es esto de acá es 240 240 pies y
queremos ver cuántos acres tiene de modo
que primero tenemos que encontrar el
área de este rectángulo de este campo en
pies cuadrados tenemos que multiplicar
240 por 363 voy a hacer la
multiplicación aquí arriba 240 240 por
363 ejercicio de multiplicar bueno vamos
a ver cuánto nos da déjame agarrar el
color morado 3 x 0 es 0 3 por 4 es 12
llevamos 13 por 12 6 y una que llevamos
es 7 ahí tenemos 720 vamos al siguiente
nivel ponemos un 0 porque corresponde a
las decenas 6 por 0 0 6 por 4 24
llevamos 26 por 2 es 12 y 2 que llevamos
14 muy bien un nivel más ahora tenemos
que poner dos ceros porque le toca a las
centenas tres por cero es 0 3 por 4 es
12 llevamos 13 por 12 6 y una que
llevamos es 7 vamos a sumar esto para
ver cuánto nos queda el área del campo
0000 200 es 274 es 11 llevamos una una y
4 5 y 27 una y 78
entonces el área de aquí es 87 mil 120
pies cuadrados pies cuadrados pero
nosotros queremos esto en acres y aquí
nos dan la conversión así si
estuviéramos en el examen para ahorrar
tiempo simplemente haríamos una
aproximación esto es aproximadamente el
doble de esta conversión que nos dan
entonces y una creación como 43 mil 87
mil van a ser como dos acres entonces yo
elegiría la opción a ahorita lo vamos a
verificar pero si quieres ahorrar tiempo
eso no tendrías que hacerlo en el examen
tomar otro color para verificar vamos a
ver cuánto es 43 mil 560 x 2 saber lo
voy a hacer donde acá 43 mil 560 por 2
para ver si de veras son dos acres dos
por cero es 0 2 por 66 12 llevamos todos
llevamos una 2 por 5 es 10 una que
llevamos 11 llevamos 12 por 13 6 y 17 2
por 4 es 887 mil 120 guau es el mismo
número
entonces en efecto son dos acres la
respuesta es a vamos ahora al problema
el problema 37 dice que el siguiente
objeto este de acá está hecho de 10
prismas rectangulares 10 prismas cada
uno con dimensiones cinco centímetros
por tres centímetros por dos centímetros
a ver se refieren a estos de acá verdad
a este por ejemplo
y este hacia acá que dice que mide que
mide cinco centímetros por tres
centímetros por dos centímetros y son 10
ok la pregunta es cuál es el volumen del
objeto en centímetros cúbicos bueno pues
vamos a calcular el volumen de uno de
estos para calcular el volumen de un
prisma hay que multiplicar ancho por
profundidad por alto sería 5 por 2 10
por 3 30 su volumen sería 30 centímetros
centímetros cúbicos el de uno de estos
uno de éstos tiene volumen de 30
centímetros
cúbicos pero nosotros queremos bueno ahí
ya no se ve muy bien el 330 centímetros
cúbicos pero nosotros queremos el
volumen de esta figura que está hecha
como de dos cruces de prismas dejar hago
la vista desde arriba desde arriba se
verían así las cinco cajas con los cinco
prismas si quieres esta sería una capa y
abajo sería otra capa es decir tenemos
cinco de éstas por capa y en total
serían diez de modo que el volumen total
de este objeto sería 10 x 30 centímetros
que sería 300 centímetros cúbicos 300
centímetros cúbicos la respuesta sería
de y lo que está un poco misterioso del
problema es estas diagonales raras que
están pintando por acá quién sabe por
qué las pintan a lo mejor es para
despistarnos y hacernos creer que el
problema tiene que ver con triángulos
pero no para nada basta encontrar el
volumen de uno de estos prismas ya vimos
que es 30 lo multiplicamos por 10 porque
son 10 prismas y con eso nos queda que
el volumen del objeto en centímetros
cúbicos es 3
la opción d